Hello Johnny what are we going to talk
about today oh I'm gonna update on how
I've been man you know in here and skid
rope still you know the things I've
accomplished and uh different things you
know I mean that that's happened to me
here you know episodes that took place
you know
big thing big thing a lot happens here
in Skid Row you know
uh first of all you know um
I've been here a total of now about say
about 10 years yeah it's been about 10
years I've been here you know I was here
first for four went and worked for my
nephew for about a year and then I came
back you know and um I was on the
streets all that time but the good thing
I could say about Skid Row is you know
they got these people going around now
and um they want everybody off the
streets I guess there's gonna be no more
homeless right now I've seen a few cops
take action and give people tickets
um I've seen a couple people hauled up
to jail you know what I mean because
they're sleeping on the sidewalk I've
got a partner that he's up in there like
on Main and and seventh that's like a
little bit outskirts and Skid Row but
he's camped out right there they made
him move like about seven times you know
and they're not being nice about it you
know if you're out here and you got in
your tent you put all your [__] in there
they're gonna come and they're gonna
give you 15 minutes to grab whatever you
can grab and they're gonna bring the
bulldozer and he just comes and he just
shoves all your [__] like it's trash you
know and a lot of the stuff that's there
are the stuff that people come and give
on the weekends you know there's people
that come every weekend and they feed
you you know I mean they give you
clothes you know they might uh give you
some help to get to get some help some
NAA but majority of them are people that
have been here before and I guess you
know they fix their lives they got
straight they joined some type of
religion or some type of group and they
come back and they feed you every week
you know and um they give you a lot of
good clothes you know I mean someone's
used something's brand new you know you
got dudes that have been here for like
10 years and they straighten up their
life where they came up somehow whether
they did it through drugs or whether
they did it through working but they
come back and they got a whole truckload
dude came back with a whole truckload of
Nike Nike shoes you know and it's like
you know it's Gabriel you can't get two
lines of people and just line it up when
we give you one box no it's not like
that it's like people attack you know
they're like ants they attack attack and
take and take you know the other day I
was we were getting some uh some
sweatsuits they were giving out
sweatsuits and this old man he [__]
just elbows me in the chest spoon real
hard I thought it was a Youngster at
first because he was kind of small
turned around he was an old man he had
gray hair and everything I was like hey
what's up what's wrong with you he's
trying to grab as many boxes he could
you know I seen him down the street
about what about 20 minutes later he has
the boxes on the side of the curves and
[__] and you know he's selling them he's
selling them and I told him hey man you
got all those boxes from that truck you
know now you're gonna come and sell them
those were given to you so you can wear
them but you know you can't tell anybody
what to do in Skid Row you know I mean
it's like it's like everybody does what
the [__] they want you know I was just
waiting down to uh uh the other day you
know I'm kicking back and you know we
got certain spots that we crowd up in
and you know people smoking buds smoking
this smoking that and we're kicking back
and I'm about to roll a joint you know
and I'm always watching looking around
and down the distance I see these two
two about me I've seen about 26 27. I
see these two Asian guys and they're
kicking the uh the parking meter you
know they're taking turns flying up and
kicking the parking meter and I pay a
little attention to myself but I'm
really not paying attention to him as
they're coming I see him again about a
block away and then when I'm about to
finish up all the joint I look up
and I hear one of the Asians tell the
other dude there's Johnny I could have
heard I could have swore I heard that
but anyways the Asian dude runs up to me
and he hits me with a double fist in the
chest okay you know he hits me and I'm
cut off surprise I I bang it to the
metal there's like some metal behind me
like like a like a warehouse I bang up
against the middle I come back me and
him start fighting we're fighting me and
one of them and then the other guy comes
from the side
boom drops me puts me on my ass you know
I've seen lights and everything hit me
so hard I fell on my ass I get up
and now I'm looking around and see if
anybody's getting in there's nobody
getting in now I don't see no brothers I
don't see no no no none of my homies
honestly I'm gonna be honest I just seen
nothing but white boys there was about
11 white boys there none of them were
jumping anything so when they're both on
me I mean me I want to equal up the
score you know I'm not gonna sit here
like I want to even up the score I want
a weapon easy as that if there's two if
there's one on one cool but if there's
two on one I need a weapon I want to
even up the score well I'm asking for a
weapon at this time these fools ain't
giving me [__] none of them is going in
their pockets no one's going in their
bags they're just looking at me I'm like
what the [__] why is the reason these
fools ain't jumping I found out after a
while the reason they didn't jump but
check it out now I asked for a weapon
they don't give me a weapon anyways this
young white dude gets up he must be
about 23 24 years old and I see this
fool get in there man and he just about
three punches he drops the first dude
the dude I'm fighting with I'm already
out of air lucky he got in he drops the
second guy once he loves the second guy
I run to the side I see my homie's bag I
reach in and I pull out a box cutter so
when I pull out the emboss cutter you
know as soon as I get close to him and
I'm gonna hit him with it they take off
they leave okay now I'm all bruised up
on the side you know I mean my nose is
bleeding a little bit I'm like you know
I'm pissed off because you know I've
been in Skid Row I've been going to that
same place for like seven years and I
figured because I was in that place I
never imagined that just people off the
streets are gonna run at me and rush me
and nobody there was gonna help me I I
was expecting for somebody to get up and
we're gonna jump these dudes you know
but being that I don't jump people I
just wanted this dude to get an ass
whooping you know I mean but I didn't
get no help from these guys uh they
didn't want to give me a weapon anything
like that reason being is this
I had my money and my weed inside my
sweater pocket now I had just pulled out
my big old bag of we know I was rolling
a joint and I put it back in his pockets
now you got guys here in skid row that
they're here and all they do all day
long is they just watch other people I
mean you might not know these guys you
mean you guys look they're just on their
bike or whatever they're just sitting
there if you don't say nothing to them
all they do is they just watch they
watch to see if the group that's will
say smoking fentanyl all the group
they're smoking fan no they're all
naughty these dudes on the bikes get off
and just collect whatever the [__] they
want and they do this every day you know
I mean and those dudes that did me like
that were there that day my weed fell
out my money fell out they just picked
it up that's what they were worried
about you know when I talked to the
girls that were there they told me man
those dudes weren't gonna get in what
they all they were waiting for was
either your money or your weed to fall
out or those guys [__] to fall out so
they could run and pick it up and that's
what happened I didn't really trip till
I got home checked my pockets and I was
like [__] what the [__] is my [__] and I
snapped and said oh I dropped it when I
was fighting with these guys and you
know you got a lot of these dudes like I
said in the schedule that come here and
they just watch they just watch they sit
there and they watch you know and I I
know because I have watched them you
know I mean and a lot of times I'm not
gonna sit here and say you know I
haven't been doing my thing I've dropped
a few
obstacle uh articles on the floor will
say and um you know certain dudes didn't
want to get it they'll send somebody
else come and get it and this dude came
down I dropped some money on the floor
the dude that seen it didn't come and
get it he sent another guy to come and
get it and could you came over here
because I was doing a drawing because I
draw a little bit I was doing a draw and
I dropped my money this dude came and
picked up my money okay now the last
food that picked up my [__] off the
ground
he had took some stuff that belonged to
me okay he took it I told him look man
just give me back my [__] will act like
it never happened he didn't want to do
that I told him look here enjoy it go
home do it and then when you come back
tomorrow I'm gonna beat your ass and
leave you on the pavement he didn't
believe me being that I'm older he
didn't believe that I was going to put
his ass on the pavement but lo and
behold he went home he came back when I
seen him the next day he's trying to
walk away I'm like hey I'm hauling his
name Eric he starts funny I walk up to
my channel where's my [__] at
give me my [__] what I ain't got your
[__] so we get busy he's younger than me
anyways I beat the [__] out of him I get
him on the ground I ground and pound
them you know what I mean hit him with
some elbows as soon as his head hit my
elbow hit the ground
but it was over now he's saying stop you
know he stopped I ain't stopping I beat
this dude up and closed his eye bust his
lip no I did that to him to set an
example because you know when you're out
here a lot of people take advantage of
others you got to be real careful
because people take advantage of of your
kindness they mistake your kindness for
weakness you know if you don't my little
homie told me you have to beat
[__] up I told them nah man why
you want to go beat people up all the
time he goes look Johnny right here you
have to establish yourself because foods
will take advantage of you and I don't
promote violence anymore I don't push
for people to hurt other people but
there are some individuals that need an
ass whooping a straight ass whooping you
know what I mean and after I gave this
dude an ass whooping you know everybody
thinks when you get somebody an ass
whooping that everybody's like oh yeah
way to go good good you know you did
good no you got the other side over here
that want to ridicule you criticize you
say you did too much you shouldn't have
did this you shouldn't have did that you
know but a couple of days ago they were
talking about you you weren't going to
do [__] now you take action and you
always got that crowd that that's the
ones I worry about is the crown that is
it is saying that I did too much that I
hurt the guy too much I shouldn't hit
him that many times you know they're
quick to criticize when you handle your
business but you have to establish your
your spot and scheduled because
everybody's
raise it to the top you know what I mean
and you know you got drug dealers you
got drug users you know you got
everything you hear everything got
prostitution you got a transvestite you
got everything you could think of in
Skid Row you know I mean and everybody's
trying to get that Mighty Dollar A lot
of people are just to get high and then
you got those other people that are here
to come up those are the guys that I
watch for the most because they're here
to come up any way they can it doesn't
matter that you're gonna drop something
they're gonna get it they're going to
get gave me the other day they gave me a
fake fifty dollar bill a fake one and
I've known this person for
um four or five years so I didn't
picture her she's a woman giving me a
fake 50 bill now she owed me forty
dollars she owed me sixty dollars she
had a lot of twenties in her wallet when
I looked but then I seen a couple 50s
and I told her well I got ten dollars
let me get this let me get to 50 and
I'll get you know and I'll give you 10.
and okay she gave it to me so I didn't
look at her I just put it in my pocket
when I went home it was a fake 50 it was
a motion picture of fake money you know
I mean and I was pissed off I ain't seen
the girl you know I I mentioned it to a
couple of people and they were like yeah
that's the way she gets down and I said
but I've known her for four or five
years I don't think she would do that to
me well I haven't seen her in like about
three or four days so apparently she
knew what she did you know and I'm not
saying I'm gonna suck her up or I'm
gonna slap her up but I have to do
something I have to do something because
if I don't the next person that comes
along is going to think they could do
the same thing and they're gonna get
away with it because I'm gonna do [__]
about it see that's what Skidmore does
to people skid will either makes you a
worse person or it betters you you know
what I mean or you're just stuck right
in the middle I was stuck right in the
middle for so long I didn't care about
having a room having my own stuff you
know I used to I used to get things like
nice things I used to find and I used to
have to give them away because I
couldn't keep them where I was where I
was sleeping in the tent because as soon
as I left boom those guys that are
waiting would just come in and take
everything and you find a lot of good
[__] here you know what I mean well what
happened was they came one day and they
came the cops came the social workers
came the people who cleaned came in
they're like hey look
we want to get you and put you in a room
we want you up the streets and I said
well how long is that going to take
they put me off the streets the same day
he said I'll take you from right here
and I'll put you in a room where you
could sleep and you know you just gotta
follow a couple of rules you just gotta
sign in and sign out when you leave you
gotta attend all the medical medical
appointments they want you to go to you
know I mean and you have to do them all
you can't be missing because they'll
just exit your ass right away because
apparently you don't want a room you
know I mean if you're not gonna be going
by what they say then you don't want a
room and there's many dudes went when I
went about six of us went and it's only
two of us left two of us left because
one guy didn't want to go to these
appointments the other fool coming home
drunk every night you know I mean acting
a fool you know I mean they got security
there you know but you know dude's
coming in with guns and knives and [__]
so a lot of dudes got kicked out you
know but they want you to do you know um
some type of um not a mental yeah it's
like a mental program you know they want
to send you to the psych and and they
want to work on if you've got depression
you know what I mean and being that a
lot of people have been incarcerated
like a lot of people that are out there
and they've been you've been
incarcerated
you can actually get housing because of
the fact that there is something wrong
with you for being incarcerated so many
years they say that something
establishes in your head and and you
tend to Resort back to the same things
and they want to help you and a lot of
them do want to help you but a lot of
them just want to get that paycheck
they're out there too you know and I
went to all my appointments and when I
went to my first appointment the dude
tells me you know um you're suffering
from depression right
you know I'm like nah nine suffering
depression he goes no you're you're
suffering from depression right
and I'm like wait a minute yeah yeah I'm
suffering from depression oh okay fine
okay this is what will do for you and
when you come back and see me again and
I'm like am I suffering from depression
at times I am something to close
something took place
really really near to me you know and
and something happened to her and she
didn't come back the same person you
know something somebody gained something
to one of my loved ones and she took it
and she overdosed on it I found her I
found her dead already she was purple
she had her physical clothes her jaws
locked you know what I mean she was
purple and she wasn't breathing oh I
took it to I pulled her off the bed you
know me and I started performing CPR I
broke one of her teeth getting us inside
her mouth because she unlocked jaw her
jaw was locked and I broke one of her
teeth getting in and um I also gave her
mouth to mouth so hard that
the next day all of a sudden my face was
swelled up I guess I blew my gum so hard
I blew into her then it blew in my gums
and it it welded up my whole face like
this was just a big old [__] ball
like that from giving her mouth to mouth
you know and um you know I noticed there
was blood when I was giving him out to
melt and I was wondering where it came
from but where it came from was when I
was at the pry her mouth open I actually
had to get my fingers in there and
opened her mouth because she had locked
jaw you know whatever he gave her
you know most people you give them
Narcan as soon as they OD you give them
Narcan and boom they snap out of it they
wake up she didn't wake up for two days
for two days and you know I was thinking
man everybody else wakes up like
right when they right when they do the
do whatever they do they they OD they
give them the Narcan and they wake right
up they just feel like [__] she didn't
wake up for two days she stayed in the
hospital seven
and I noticed when she came back
she ain't the same person and it bugs me
it bugs me because I'm not saying she
came back slow or she came back [__]
or nothing like that what I'm saying is
she did not come back the same person I
know and the reason I know is because
I've been around her for 20 years and I
know her habits I know the way she talks
when she gets mad when she gets she's
happy none of that exists anymore none
of that exists anymore she just lays
there and and she don't even she can't
even hold a conversation with me and
that's what's eating me up the most
because yeah you know I brought her back
and everything you know and I helped her
she she was dead when I found her but I
brought her back but did I really bring
her back I mean if we were in unskid
world would that have happened you know
an individual that gave it to her he's a
jump man you know he's a chump you know
I mean he he gave it to her he panicked
he left her there I found her you know
and eats me up every day because really
I want to hang this [__] on I'm
just gonna be honest I'm gonna hang this
phone a hook I just want to hang him on
a hook for the simple fact it he got
away with that [__] you got away with
that [__] because it never got reported
we never said nothing about it but dude
sits there in this woman acting all cool
and [__] and I just want to slap him I
want to just slap him hard as [__]
because
even though I brought her back I brought
her back but she's not the same person
she's not the same person I met she's
not the one I fell in love with a long
time ago she's not the one that I've
known this long she's just a different
person you know I mean and that's what
Skid Row did to me skid was doing these
things to me it may not have took her
but he took a part of her that that I
remember you know I mean and I try and
speak to her but she's she just she's
not there she's not there don't don't
get me wrong she knows all the phone
numbers what day it is where she's at
who's the president and all that [__]
but I'm saying her her well-being her
her the way her Aura was before it's not
there it's gone you know her aura's gone
and it and and it eats me up inside
because I'm thinking was I supposed to
let her die
am I am I wrong for bringing her back
and she didn't come all the way back
because I know that you only need five
minutes without air oxygen to your brain
and you become a vegetable no I don't
know if she was dead there one minute
two three I don't know but it must have
been two or three because she's not the
same person and and she eats me up
because she used to be real loud
outgoing talking and everything and now
she won't say nothing
she don't say [__] unless I address her
you know and I try to have conversations
with her and I'm going to look for help
for her because I know she needs some
help because there's things inside she
wants to get out and I guess she don't
know how you know but those are the
things that that Skid Row takes from you
and I wasn't there you know I didn't
know what she did or anything like that
I had to do my own little investigation
and find out that this [__] dummy you
know what I mean figured because I use
something that she uses it and it wasn't
like that she don't use what I use and
he figured well oh you ain't feeling
good oh I know what he uses so she uses
it too so he gave it to her her not ever
seen it smoked in this certain it would
say a bong
um she didn't know what it was she
thought it was something else and anyway
she Odin on me and she's been back for
like a month and a half and she's back
and she's just back physically mentally
she's not there with me you know I mean
it upsets me every day you know but
that's a little message out there to let
you people out there know man that you
can come here and yeah they might have
good drugs and all that but this drug
will [__] you up now what they're doing
with the fentanyl is they're adding
something in it now and it's called
shrank it's called tranquilizer it's
what they call it trank you know and I I
didn't know until me and my homies were
[__] around and we got some new [__]
and we tried it out and put me dead on
my ass you know what I mean dead on my
ass or I was falling down you know and I
never fall down I don't get up here and
lie and say that I don't use drugs I'm
never gonna say that I don't deny the
facts but I'm being careful now because
they got some [__] out here now that
it's 10 times 20 times stronger than
Fentanyl and Fentanyl is supposed to be
100 times stronger than heroin
you know at times I'm not going to rely
I'm going to tell the truth to Bear
because I always do
sometimes I wish I would have stayed
doing heroin
I know it doesn't sound right saying
that but at times I wish I did because
the style
and the people that come with this
fentanyl there's no love there there's
no consideration there's no kindness you
know you before with Heroin I could see
I could be sick and my homie would see
me and he'd be like amen you see come on
man I'll get you out come on Boom but
with fentanyl dude could be laying on
the ground throwing up his guts [__]
on himself and no one helps them no one
else if no one says hey man you want a
little head you need some nobody and I
that was the first thing I seen and then
the second thing I seen was I don't know
what the [__] it is but people's skin
just people's skin on their body is is
catching a a flesh eating bacteria and
it's not just one type there's like four
different types of it I seen a girl with
on the bottom of her knees all the way
around her leg you can see her bone in
both legs you can see the actual bone I
mean it was just big old holes in there
and they weren't healed and they had
scabs or nothing it was still all wet in
there you can steal them but you can see
her bones she just passed away like a
ball last month you know I had helped
her across the street one day two days
later she was dead in her apartment from
her legs I got another homie that he has
he has this other [__] that it starts
from his knees all the way to the tips
of his toes and it's just a gang of
Swords a lot of swords and their deep
ass swords deep and they don't scab up
that's when I was like I was tripping
because when you get a cut you know they
scab up but for some reason this flesh
any bacteria that's hitting all these
people in skiro it does not heal up it
doesn't heal up and doing fat no you're
only making it worse because what
fentanyl does is it makes your legs
swell up you know when your legs swell
up everybody who's been using fentanyl
for a little while and I talked to them
everybody's legs are swelled up you know
your socks they like they make they make
a Groove inside your skin where it's
real small and then your legs just blow
up and it starts to hurt after a while
you know what I mean and everything from
from uh that that [__] they put out here
it's long term although sex are
long-term you got all kinds of dudes
walking around here with the Crooked
back with a crooked back and ask them
hey what's up with your Batman wasn't
all my back hurts I told me it's not
your back it's your kidneys that's what
it is because they don't attacks the
kidneys and it's your kidneys I see
you're not drinking enough water you
know what I mean uh and and fat no it
drains you from everything it takes
everything out your body it takes all
the water you have in your body and it
just takes it you know I mean you have
to keep drinking water drinking water
but a lot of people out here don't
really realize or give a [__] about
drinking water no one's thinking about
their health out here you know and then
those are the other dude I've seen they
they chopped they went from his first
hole one then they went all his toes
then they went half his foot then with
his ankle his knee and then they went
right here oh that reminds me right here
check this out about a month ago I'm
walking it's about six six or seven in
the morning I'm walking I see the fire
truck I see the fire engine I'm like oh
[__] there was a building that had
burned down and they gutted it when they
gutted the building they got it the
basement too so you can look down and
see you know where where it's under the
street and [__] well I'm looking at the
other the day before the day before I
seen these fire trucks there I looked
down and I seen somebody sleeping down
there and I was like always asleep down
there for how the [__] you get in the
camera right there and it goes off and
starts talking [__] that someone's in
the property get out of here you know
what I mean well I'm looking down while
the feeling dad came back I seen the
fire trucks there I went well I went
around the fire truck and I looked
they were taking out a body that his
left arm and his left leg were gone
there was it was it was cut all the way
from here
and all the way up here not here no
right here then he had a bag around his
face
and one of his legs he just had one leg
one arm and her had a black boot it was
a long black boot it was about this high
and he had a uh he had a black shirt on
but he hadn't bag and it was zip tied
around around his neck and they they
were they had this little crane from the
from the fire department they had this
little crane going over the fence and it
had you know when you put up a person
lays in he had one of those little
buckets and it was going down you know
and his young kids walking by and
they're like they're looking they're
being like well you hate that guy the
guy don't have an arm or leg I mean arm
or a leg and it's in the bag and they're
tripping they get their cameras off and
looking I don't know what happened to
this guy but I could just imagine the
pain he went through because he didn't
have his whole left side was gone and it
looked surgically cut it didn't look
like somebody chopped it it looked like
they cut it and packed it and then you
know I mean the bag around his head
I don't know but I remember seeing this
dude the day before I thought he was
asleep but it was actually a body you
know what I mean and that was just what
a block of Fame a block away from where
we sleep I didn't hear nothing I didn't
see [__] we're up all night I didn't see
nothing and there's a big ass six foot
fence so to get him over they had to get
him over and throw his ass over you know
what I mean but there was no property by
him or nothing but it just looked weird
because the body his body didn't really
look right and the reason was is because
the whole left side was gone I didn't
see his they weren't putting his leg out
or his arm out from anywhere it just
wasn't there but I watched for about 20
minutes and no they didn't they didn't
find no leg they didn't find no arm they
just found that one piece of body you
know what I mean and it's it it it it it
reminded me of like you know the TV
shows that I watch on TV you know I mean
but it was real life you know I mean and
I know these little kids that seen it I
was thinking these girls are getting
traumatized you know me because they're
young they're like 16 17 and they're
like oh [__] he don't have one you know
and they're talking amongst each other I
can hear them oh they told that torture
probably you know and they're knowing
what time it is and they're young you
know and I'm thinking damn this is what
the you see over here you know I mean
that [__] you know I mean that shit's
not cool I mean it's not cool at all you
know what I mean and then every night we
have to go through [__] loud ass
explosions I'm talking about these
explosions are so loud that there was
one the other day
it must have been a block and a half
away but I felt not just me the guys
that were there we felt like a ripple
come through us from when when it
exploded a few seconds later you feel
like a rip will come through us and I
was like what the [__] was that and the
dude was trying to say that was you know
when something explodes you know it
pushes air and and I actually felt that
it scared the [__] out of me but I
actually felt the air you know and I was
wondering what is it what what's what's
exploding so loud that I can't even
recognize it's not a door slamming it's
it's not a firecracker it's not a
firework something's blowing up so the
other one night when it was blowing up
on this side over here on like the east
side of Skid Row I heard it I seen a
Flash and I said I'm gonna go over there
and check so I went over there and
checked and when I checked what it was
is you have the manhole the one they
take out and they were climbing and
finish to fix the pipes the manhole was
still there but about eight feet
around the manhole the whole street was
gone the whole street was gone it was
just a big ass hole and I said is that
what exploded you know what I mean and
we hear them frequently like every other
night one time I heard seven of them in
Monroe they were trying to tell me those
are Transformers blowing up [__] no I
had to go look myself and when I looked
part of the street was gone they had an
officer right there with yellow tape he
wasn't letting nobody drive because your
car go dead in there you know and it's D
it's it's deep down here you know
there's other things other places in
schedule you can look down and grates
and [__] and you can see down there how
far 40 feet 40 foot drops and you can
tell there's rooms down there there's
hallways and everything you know they
say people live down there me myself I
haven't been down there I had a homie
that said he was living down there and
for the whole month he was missing and
then he shows up and I'm like where the
[__] you been in jail no I was down
there down where
beneath us down there and they call it
the city below and I'm like what the
[__] what are you talking about he's
like I was down there they didn't let me
come out now they let me come out
they who's there he said oh well the
people down there not because just
anybody could go down there and people
think it's a mess you know man people
think it's [__] [__] you know I've
seen [__] go down there I I
seen the way people get in there you
know I mean and there's things the way
you get in there is there's certain
areas where
there's a door right here and this door
leads nowhere but if you go behind the
door in the bushes you can go down it's
just certain areas they got certain ways
to get in and it took me five years to
find one of the ways in and I heard
about it and they told me that right
here right here never found them
accidentally stumbled on one of them I
still stumbled on one of them or it was
a five steps and then you walk in it
five steps more and then you just went
into a square a square tunnel and it
went below all the buildings because I
was all the way up on bouldering Boulder
is Boulder is behind the buildings on
the other side on I was saying on the on
the west side of of La I was standing on
that side of the building and I found
that whole where it's not a water drain
because there's a water drain on the
side of it I don't know what the [__] is
doing there but they told me when you
find a way in that place you're gonna
tell yourself this is not supposed to be
here and it's not supposed to be there
that's the first thing I thought like
what the [__] is this here for you know
there's nothing for you there's no use
to it and I watched it and I went in a
little bit and I noticed that it went
under all the streets I didn't go in
there because it's really dark I didn't
have flashlights they had a lighter and
that [__] didn't work it only worked for
a little while and it went out but you
know I won't go down there unless I got
about 10 [__] with me because I
don't know who's down there
who runs the [__] down there but I did
my homie was going in and out in and out
and then his girlfriend found him dead
in his room you know and I feel about a
lot of people are dying right here and
everybody's saying oh we die from
fentanyl oh he died from fentanyl oh he
died from Fentanyl and half these
[__] don't use Fentanyl
that's why I'm saying how can a
[__] die from fentanyl when he
doesn't even use fentanyl you know I
mean that that's a lot a lot of people
are saying that diarrhea oh he died
setting up and he don't even [__] use
fentanyl I mean or if I got a phone with
a needle in his arm that [__]
don't use needles that fool don't even
use drugs you know how the [__] did he
die from amusing uh a syringe you know I
mean it's just a lot of [__] right they
had another lady over here in the Cecil
that they found her with her mouth and
her nose super glued shut
[Music]
and super glue her nose shut like they
put glue in there and then they shut it
so she couldn't breathe or nothing and
this lady must have been like a bar when
I seen her she was about me about 60.
and she was a loud ladies she used to
used to talk [__] but she's also let a
lot of people inside her house and she
was neighbors to my homegirl you know
what I mean and I went over there and we
seen her way up there across the street
and then two days later my uncle tells
me hey they found that lady right there
with her mouth
glued shirt and that's at the season
Motel a lot of people know where to see
some Motown there's so much here I've
seen there you believe it two weeks ago
I'm with my homegirl in her room and she
goes look she would look out the window
I look at the window she goes look at
the phone she goes that's you know I
recorded last week and then I look at
the phone closer there's a female girl
hanging
from the seventh story
she they said she put her on her neck
closed the window I don't know how the
[__] she closed the window but she's
hanging
with a sheep from the seventh floor and
it's I'm watching on the video and
everybody's screaming from their back
window on the video you know and the
windows I could see where where she was
hanging at but I'm looking at her and
she's hanging in
when I first pushed play on the video
her feet were still kicking so she
wasn't dead yet her feet are kicking
those people yelling at her pull her up
they're [__] trying to pull her up
they don't got enough strength they
can't get her so I hear somebody yell
the other person go to the floor She
said go to the go to the next floor down
I guess they went to the sixth floor
dude opened the window she's still below
that [__] I don't know how much she she
put but she's still hanging right there
she's dead by now and and man it looks
so bad because they're pulling her up
and she's hitting everything boom boom
she's hitting the pipe she's hitting the
wall going back and forth and then man
oh man God was sick man her pants fall
down man and her pants come off you know
so it was it was it was a scene that you
only see in the movies man I never
pictured anything like this you know and
people actually have video of it you
know what I mean and they're pulling her
up man she's not a big woman she's not
that big but you could tell the dudes
that are pulling her up they're [__]
struggling I can't I can't put her
[__] in people are yelling and
screaming well I need this big dude
comes and he pulls her and pulls her and
pulls her and then he just reaches out
and grabs her by her face right here but
since she he just rips her in the womb
but she's dead so we find out well why
did she kill herself she killed herself
because her old man was acting [__] up
and she kept telling him if you leave me
I'll kill myself if you leave me I kill
myself she had tried it three previous
times
and succeeded the fourth time he only
succeeded but what I tripped on is the
windows there are just real big they
open like this and they close like this
she was hanging from a window that was
closed
I I couldn't see her get there's no way
you can fit on the edge of the window
and you're gonna jump off and be able to
close the window at the same time that
doesn't make sense because when she they
try to get to her the dude's like the
Windows shut the [__] window shut it
was shut her sheet went out and the
window was shut on it
you know who so who knows what the [__]
happened but I don't think she shut the
window when she jumped down I don't
think so another dude my homie right
down the street over here he goes and he
goes by some PCP he [__] dips it he
goes to the fifth he's in the fifth
Story
his door is right by the end of the Ring
and there's nothing over there he
[__] smokes a [__] PCP and that
[__] backs up and falls off the
on five stories he fall backwards and
flipped all the way down he don't
remember [__] what saved his [__]
life was there was a refrigerator right
there he hit the refrigerator he hit the
refrigerator split his whole arm open he
got all kinds of bolts
he broke his back he got to about seven
seven uh uh still rods in his back I
mean he [__] up the side of his face
but he lived he don't remember nothing
how they found him somebody didn't find
him somebody's dog was out there gonna
use the bathroom and went around the
corner and [__] found him the person
followed their dog and boom found him
laying there he had been laying there
for like about an hour and he fell for
five stories I seen him the other day he
was doing push-ups and this just
happened to him last year you know I
mean and I told him the reason you lived
was because you smoked that PCP and when
you fell you never braced for impact a
lot of people don't know that when you
fall if you brace you get hurt more than
if you didn't brace at all and you did
so what he was he just balanced but he
[__] ripped all his [__] up he scars
all over his body but he lived you know
what I mean why he smoked some PCP I
said do you remember anything goes I
don't remember nothing just dipping it
hitting it
and then I woke up in the hospital I
said man he was in the hospital for me
six months but he's out here now doing
push-ups and everything he's cool
another fool was up there at the at the
Rosalind and and it's a trip because
okay you got the Ross and you got all
the windows on the runs in now there's a
fire in his room but it just stayed in
his room in those little towns if a room
Burns it's just that one
it doesn't burn anywhere else it's a
trip because there's rooms up there and
they're just they got that black smoke
coming out you know because black smoke
comes out the windows and it stains the
outside but one room though only one it
doesn't catch into the Next Room the
next and I'm like what the [__] how does
how does that happen did they actually
make the building they're so old they
actually make it more only one Burns
because the other time we see anyone
burning flames were coming out of it
flames and flames and the other rooms on
the other side weren't even burning they
weren't burning the walls it was just
burning all the [__] inside and those
rooms are really small and that's where
that's where they put everybody you know
they put you in one of these motels for
a couple of months and then they give
you a one bedroom somewhere and it's
just one of these motels that they
converted into a place where you can
live now you know but but you know they
like the cecils oh I wouldn't want to
live there at all at all I'm in my
uncle's pad we're kicking it we're
drinking some beers and I hear a knock
on the door I'm gonna go she goes don't
go get it no one's there shut the [__]
up man knock again I'm gonna answer it I
go open the door nobody I said now man
close the door I walk away knock boom I
turn off in I said no what I'm gonna do
is I'm gonna wait right with the door
handle when I hear that knock I'm gonna
[__] rip it open and see if he was
there as soon as I heard the knock I
ripped it open nobody there nobody and
that's at the Cecil you know they tell
me that place is haunted [__] yeah I've
been there and I've seen a lot of [__] I
say at least
four to five people die every two months
in a season whether they hang themselves
they overdose they just get they get
killed they find it they find them dead
in the room but the Cecil's just like I
wouldn't want to live there if they told
me hey you can live well I want to be
good in the season no way but no it's
it's true it's too Eerie in there when
you walk down the hall when you go to
the bottom oh my God I went to the
Bottom by myself like at two in the
morning I'll never go down there again
you know because they got all the
microwaves and all the all the it's like
down there it's rebuilt but you can tell
it's real old but what they did was they
rebuilt it you know they they put fresh
paint fresh you know cement whatever and
and it's nice as [__] down there don't
get me wrong the sea salt is nice the
the basement it's nice everything's
brand new the refrigerators and
everything
but I'm the only [__] down there
there's nobody else down there and I'm
like [__] that I put I put my uh hot
water for like five minutes and I got
the [__] out of there because I didn't
like the feeling I didn't like the
feeling there's a lot of buildings here
in downtown that when you go in there it
feels like you step into a whole
different spot you mean a whole
different realm you know and there's
there's all kinds of different people
here man there's so many different
people here I mean there's people from
from all the countries that come down
here you know and there's a lot of a lot
of people that approach you and they're
like hey can you take me over here I'll
pay you can you do this for me I'll pay
you you know and a lot of dudes even
want to pay people that live in the
season just to take them in there as a
visitor usually giving 100 200 300 just
to take them in there so they could take
pictures you know those dudes that are
infatuated with that Motel you know what
I mean and you know me myself I go by
there but I kick it on the upper side
now I used to kick in in the bottoms but
you know it it it it it got to it got
that that disease that's going around I
don't want it you know I mean I don't
want to catch it and I don't know how
you catch it if you have an open wound
and you don't take care of it or if you
touch something and then you scratch
yourself you know and there's a lot of
dudes that have it and and they pick up
their leg in front of everybody and they
start cleaning it and then they just
throw the [__] towels they've been
cleaning it on the [__] ground I'm
like get a [__] bag dude you don't
mean you want to come around us your
[__] laser like that you don't want
to go to the doctor because you don't
want to miss anything but you're [__]
cleaning this [__] and then you're just
throwing the paper on the side of the
[__] road and we're the ones that
come and clean it up
we're not no gloves we ain't gonna they
give us a lot of hand sanitation but
it's sanitizer but you know we don't got
no gloves and you got dudes that I mean
there was one dude all this [__] part
of this guy was missing was just gone
and you can see his [__] bone you can
see the actual bone in there and I'm
telling him doesn't it [__] hurt he's
like ah a little bit you know he's
[__] cleaning the inside of it and oh
my God it looks nasty I have another
homie that he's [__] maggots fall out
of his legs and he puts them back in I'm
like what are you doing
no that's good they're good for me oh my
god dude what are you talking about
maggots will fall out he'll get to make
it and put it back in I'm like where are
you [__] where did you hear this
nonsense at I said when you have maggots
in your body that's because you're dead
you know you have maggots in your leg
because that [__] leg is dead you
know what I mean and I'm talking about
[__] where you could see them moving
around in there you know what I mean the
maggots don't stop moving and they'll
fall down and that fool would actually
get them put them back in and I was like
what the [__] are you doing he said oh
they eat up the infection the infection
your [__] infections your whole
[__] leg man you got to take those
[__] out of there you can't
just relate them that's the large one
you can't just let them sit in there and
eat they're eating your [__] body you
know what I mean another [__] homie
was walking and a piece of meat fell off
the bottom of his pants and I'm like
what the [__] is that he's like oh man I
don't worry about that it's just a piece
of my leg what the [__] I seen it was
with hair on it a piece of me with hair
on it from his from his [__] leg and
I mean where where I don't I try to um I
try to understand them I try to say what
what keeps you from going to the
hospital when you're that bad off when
your [__] body's falling apart
literally your body's falling apart it's
dying in front of you oh man and the
smell
but I'm talking about 15 feet away
it smells bad it's dead flesh so it
smells like there's a dead body and then
dude's kicking it you know he thinks
everything might be dressed real nice
has some nice clothes on his [__] but
the [__] smell of that I asked him
like I don't mean no disrespect but how
do you get with women like that there's
no cologne you could put no [__]
nothing you can spray any kind of smell
you can put to stop that smell and it's
it's death it's [__] rotten flesh and
if you never smell that it's a smell
where it [__] just sticks right here
you know and it don't go nowhere you
know I mean until you get the [__] out
of there the other day we're kicking on
some benches or they're on Spring a
little spot we're at and some dude
walked up and he sat like 15 feet away
and when we caught the down down draft
of him
man I almost threw up man I I couldn't I
told my homie how the [__] is that dude
stand the smile himself you know what I
mean is he so used to it I got a
homemade High School questions all the
time because both of these legs are
[__] up and I asked them I said how do
you get used to that smell
you know they kick him out of uh
different places he goes to I go in that
doesn't that doesn't bother you that you
can't go in this place over here because
the smell of your leg you you it doesn't
eat you up inside it I mean me it would
bother me if they would tell me you got
to leave because you [__] his mouth
I mean but it don't bother them I don't
know what the [__] I don't know what
they put in their head to make them feel
like that's not something they got to
take care of you know I mean and the
[__] kills you have to say you know it
affects you so long that once you hit
your bloodstream you're dead you're
[__] dead I don't give a [__] who you
are so many people have died from that
[__] and they always say oh you die from
fentanyl [__] no he had both his legs
just eaten up you know what I mean and
don't get me wrong there's maggots flies
everything are coming you know I mean
everything's coming to [__] eat that
[__] you know I mean and dudes like like
I told him he just take all those
maggots out and he will not take the
Magnus out of his leg and I said dude
you're not supposed to have worms in
your body
somebody told him that it was okay and
he ran with that he thinks it's okay he
thinks that the maggots are going to eat
his [__] and he's going to get better
you're not going to get better the only
way you're going to get better if you go
to the hospital and you sit in there for
a couple of months but all these dudes
down here in skid rolls they don't want
to go to the hospital not because
they're running or they got warrants or
they want it but no they just don't want
to go because they don't want to go
because they don't have no dope that's
what they told me I said why don't you
want to go because I don't have enough
dope to take with me to go so if I give
you no dope You're Gonna Go
yeah give him the door [__]
don't go he just goes around the corner
and goes the other side and you're like
hey what the [__] I gave you all that to
go and you didn't even go a lot of dudes
do that you got fools out here that is
real sick and [__] and then they'll roll
around everybody hey man I'm going to
the hospital could you help me out and
they'll go by everybody and collect and
then they won't even go you know I mean
they won't even go and that's what you
deal with down here in skid row it's not
just the cops or the city or the no but
you deal with your own environment and
all the people around you and they're
all different shades of [__]
you know you got [__] that damn
walking down the street telling me damn
she's beautiful man look at how
beautiful and then she gets close and
you're like oh [__]
you know I mean you ain't looking no
more because it's a man but yet she
looked from a distance she looked like a
model but she gets up and then you see
those broad shoulders and that deep ass
voice and you're like damn you know what
I mean just the other day me and three
moments are kicking it and there's some
there was a beautiful one who walked up
and it was it was a man and we thought
it was a woman and we're like I bet you
that's a man no it's not a man it's a
woman look at that she had curved body
heard everything eyes pulled back
everything woman hell or not it was a
straight man and she let it be known
right when she got there because my
homie's like what's up you want to party
and she said well I'm transgender and I
heard it I was like oh she said she's
transgender and and I I clown the homie
but I couldn't clone them that much
because a minute ago I was saying look
at that beautiful ass girl man look at
that pretty ass girl coming down here
and it was a man it was actually a man
you know you got some that don't care
they look like dudes but they want to
dress like women but you could tell it's
a dude but then you got those other ones
that you need to be careful because a
lot of homies have got with them went
out with them kissed them and all that
[__] and then they find out through a
man you know what I mean and it's [__]
up you know that the person don't say it
but a lot of these transgenders and
these these amorphic or more for
amorphic or something like that you know
they have both sexes they let it be
known a lot of them let it be known you
know I mean and I didn't realize that
Spring Street that's where they're all
at onto the spring gallon spring that's
what we're all at all on Spring and I
didn't know this I was going to the
restaurants right there and everything
and then I started looking around and
seeing boy and boy action I'm like what
the hell I mean what's going on here and
then I found out after a little while oh
spring is where all the people you know
that that choose to be with the same sex
live at even in the Lofts and even the
loss you know they got a lot of money
you know what I mean all the freaky ones
that dress all weird and [__] they're
all in Spring you know what I mean but
right now what they're doing in Skid Row
is they're eliminating everybody who's
homeless pretty soon they're gonna make
it if you're homeless
you're breaking the law if you're
sleeping on the sidewalk you're breaking
the law how they're going to do that I
don't know but from from what I'm seeing
is they're taking everybody off the
streets but when I trip on is the dude
that they come and they tell him hey
we'll put you in a room right now nah
I'm cool
you don't want to get up the streets
nope and they're honest about it I got a
homie that I try to sit with him and
tell them another dog just get a room
and you can [__] come back out here
just have a room where you can sleep you
can put your clothes you can put your
stuff so nobody will take your [__] no
I'm all right right here
under a [__] tarp right next to some
[__] uh just got a few two by fours
and a [__] pellet and puts the tarp
over it and he's all right right there
when they done offered him a room five
times anywhere of his choosing you know
because sometimes you get to choose
where you go you know what I mean and he
don't want to leave he don't want to
leave and I don't understand why you
know man I ask him time and time again
you're the only [__] out here
there was like 15 20 of us he's the only
one just him by himself and they got him
moving from here to there to here to
there to here and I tell them man you
can't even sleep in my van bro just get
off the streets because you don't mean
they're on your ass you know and he
wants to do his thing and be in the
spotlight and I told him come on man the
other day he put his tent up and right
behind him was a daycare center I told
him what he's doing you can't be in
front of this daycare center and you're
getting all high when you get busted
they crack your ass when you get to
court that judge is gonna see where you
were at in front of a school or a
daycare center you have to be 500 feet
away you're right in front and then you
got [__] coming down kicking
back smoking and [__] you got kids
walking out come on bro you gotta have
some type of respect down here you know
a lot of these dudes don't man they'll
[__] light something up right in
front of somebody's mom me and I'm I'll
go inside or I'll go in a tent or I'll
stash but you got dudes out here that
just don't give a [__] they'll smoking
right there in front of dudes Grandma
dudes mom and you can hear the people
talking about I look at him you know
he's smoking a piping glass they don't
even try
trip on the most are the ones that are
still using the needle you know they
just use the needle and then they just
throw it they don't break the tent they
don't break the back they just use the
needle and throw it even when they go in
and they leave blood in there they just
throw it on the street I've argued with
so many [__] that did that
where I'm like look at that needle you
just do that's blooding and everything
it still gets a point on it somebody
reach down grabs it or touches and you
give them a disease come on man that's
why they got those [__] red things
they give you from [__] needle
exchange you know needles change comes
around and they handle cookies and rigs
they handle everything clean spray so
there's rice contain their abscesses and
[__] but [__] just don't do it
my folks don't do it you got people
walking on a big old ball like this on
the net
bigger ball like that other net purple
you can't even move their [__] head
you know then you got other ones that
are stuck like this the change is stuck
in their chest they they got a big old
[__] ball there I don't know what it
is it's not a muscle they don't got no
pool muscle it's just a big ass [__]
ball like right here and they can't pick
their head up no more because it's just
right there and they gotta walk like
that all day when they talk to you they
look up like what's up and I'm like man
okay you can't even you wouldn't even be
able to push their head back because
they got these big old [__] balls and
I don't know what the [__] it is you
know because
most of them use the same thing I use
and and why am I getting what they are
catching you know what I mean because
they say oh what's inside this drug or
what's inside this drug but yet
I'm doing this I sometimes mess with
this you know or that but I don't get
what those dudes got you know what I
mean and it's it's nasty it's just the
way they look you know their appearance
you know I mean like if you see four or
five dudes all the same way with their
bad son Stover or all day long they're
just bent over I'm like man how can you
do that all day long you know you don't
get a headache you don't get a Head Rush
nothing but it's just that's what
Skidmore does to a [__] Skittle
Skittle like like it invites
[__] in and then they hold you
captive it holds you captive word you
don't want to go to the hospital and the
hospitals are free you don't even want
to go to the clinic why because you
don't want you don't want to miss sunken
and I don't know what the [__] you're
missing but somebody it's always like
you don't want to miss something you
know like you're going to leave and
they're gonna give out a million dollars
to everybody while you're gone [__] that
ain't gonna happen but dudes actually
believe that
if they leave right now they're gonna
[__] miss out on something and I I
I've paid fools I've gave full [__] to
go to the hospital you know just because
of the fact that now that they have and
then decaying flesh they have you know
me and I've seen it before and but now
you see it on women
women that's what I don't understand
when I see the women and they got that
I'm like you're a woman man you got to
keep yourself up a little bit better you
know they don't give a [__] I got 100
that walks around all day like this
I don't know if I brought her over here
but she walks like this all day and and
I told you your neck don't hurt and this
girl
I used to chase her around I wanted to
be with her now I see her and I'm like
[__] what happened that's what skid Rose
Skid Row did to her she came in
beautiful she was beautiful and now I
see her not saying she ain't beautiful
anymore she just don't look right and
that's what Skid Row does you know what
I mean but I I just wanted to get up
here and allow people to see me again
because you know they've seen videos of
me and a lot of them I get a lot and a
lot of the comments I get you know you I
seen you go up and down up and down I
was like yeah well that's how it is like
a roller coaster ride you know one time
I look all tore up and loaded up next
time I look like I'm better right now I
think I'm better than any other time
because of the fact I've been going to
the doctor I've been going to my
appointments you know seeing the doctor
and all that [__] taking the medication
I still talk with my eyes closed I
always do that a lot of people ask why I
feel more like I'm in the picture you
know I feel like I picture everything on
my mind what I'm talking about you know
that's why I have my eyes closed a lot
because I'm speaking so I that people
always asking always asking comes why
are your eyes closed it's not because
I'm loaded it's just that I'm in the
thinking process and you know I want to
talk about things that are interesting
you know I mean I have them going in my
mind things that happen here you know I
mean high-speed chases that happen in
the middle of the night you know I mean
your mother foods are doing 100 down the
road you know what I mean with people
throwing [__] out the window you don't
mean throwing guns out everything and
the cops are chasing them everywhere you
know I mean the helicopters are going
around and around Gangnam [__] then
you hear gunshots going off right here
nightly nightly loud ass gunshots you
know people getting killed left and
right I think
since I've been here I'll say
20 to 30 of my friends are dead
and I've been here yeah for the 10 years
I've been here I say 20 to 30
of my friends are dead
half of them are dead from Odin
a third of them are dead they got killed
and the other ones died
some of the mysterious ways but a lot of
the people that were here are here no
more they're all dead I bet you half
those people that came on the channel
you have half of them one-third of them
are dead someone dies every uh someone
dies every every couple of days
someone's dying someone's dying
someone's dying and I'm like damn you
know I mean I even got me a Sparks to
jug bottle the plastic ones and all my
change I put in there
and I told you know her my my friend I
told her look when I die you know I'm
Gonna Fill This jar up when I die this
is what you use to bury me because I
don't want you to ask nobody for [__]
none of my family don't ask them for no
help this jar that I'm [__] putting
all is changing if I put enough change
in there for long enough time you use
that to bury me don't ask nobody for
[__] because a lot of people out here
are dying and and I see him having like
little car washes or some type of little
fundraiser or you know can you help up
bury somebody in me the way I think is
I'll just feel this jar fill this
plastic container up as much as I can
and you know if I get it halfway or
almost full it should be enough to bury
me you know because I know a dude had
one it was a lot of money but I just put
my change in every day and I already
told the person who could get access to
it and look when I die you grab that
thing and you pay for me to get buried
or whatever you have to do you know what
I mean because
you die out here and they let you lay on
the cement for like six seven hours put
a sheet around you and then they just
take you and haul you off boom and
you're gone and you're forgotten you're
forgotten people bring you up here and
there but you're forgotten you know and
a lot of the dudes come to me and you
get ahead of that what the [__] you're
getting a hit of this you ever smoke
this [__] what the [__] you want to hear
for this [__] will kill you man not just
a little I'll just take a little you
don't understand that just a little hit
will kill you I go look I don't give a
[__] if you want to die but what about
when your mom and your sisters or your
old lady or your wife comes over here
and I have to explain to them why the
[__] do you die because you didn't bet
on you don't even [__] with it but yet
you want to get so [__] high you want
to take a little hit there's no such
thing as a little head
you know I mean people say I'll just
I'll just take a look there's no such
thing as a little hit man you take a
[__] hit you die but [__]
still insist I want to hit and you can
tell them look you're gonna die if you
hit this I don't know just give me a hit
still
see another dude had a gun to his head
and he's like I'm gonna kill you he's
like could I take another hit first what
the [__]
and that was in the bathroom I just
introduced in the store and do that and
they said he's like well can I take a
hit First Take a Hit first before he
killed man that's the sickest [__] I've
ever seen I've seen it twice like that
already the first time I seen it the
second time I seen it again I said these
[__] are crazy why would a fool
want to take a hit and they get killed
right after but I mean that's what
skateboard brings out I mean a lot of
people that got up on camera and speak
on your thing a lot of people I pass
through traffic out here and you know
they say what's up you know I see you oh
yeah I see you too you know and I get a
lot of people that approach me and they
approach me in the right fashion you
know what I mean but there's some people
that follow me and I'd be like what the
[__] you been following me for like two
hours I'll even go inside a restaurant
and sit down and they'll come in the
restaurant and sit down and watch me and
I'm like who are these people you know I
mean I don't know who they are if
they're fans or they like what I say or
maybe you know part of the fan club but
they never approach they're just always
watching so now wherever I'm at I turn
around boom someone's watching I hear my
name this side this way this way and I
don't mind all that don't bug me what
bugs me is when a person follows me and
they don't come and introduce themselves
or meet me you know there's other guys
that come and oh man my wife's in love
with you man oh there she is right there
and the wife's looking and she's smiling
and I'm like ask your wife Minnie oh no
she's in love you man can we take a
selfie oh that's cool I love all that
that's good to me I feel good about that
because I'm reaching people a lot of
guys are saying hey man I got your
message or I heard what you're saying
man keep it up you know when are you
gonna do some more you know that's why
I'm here you know and I got other things
to talk about but I want what I'm gonna
do is I'm gonna put them like in a
format so I don't come in here and
repeat myself on the same [__] I've
talked about before you know but I got a
lot to hear that I want I want to put
down you know a lot of people are asking
to hear but you know it's been so much
[__] happening out here right now with
my personal life that it's kind of
caught me up especially with her on Dean
on me and she came back and she's not
the same person you know so now I got to
deal with her just laying there and I
gotta go out there and buy for something
to eat I gotta go out there and get her
what she needs because she didn't go out
there and get it for herself that's what
I'm talking about her response time is
different you know so it's not like I'm
alone you know I thought you know I
brought it back everything was cool
everything's not cool because you'll
just later until I tell her hey we want
to go somewhere why don't you go down
the street over here and then she'll get
up and she'll go but she doesn't do
anything voluntarily
you know I mean she'll go to the store
and buy me something once in a while but
she's not there and that's what skid
will took for me Skid Row didn't take
her last Gabriel took a part of her soul
you know she didn't come back the same
person and and eats me up because when I
found her she was gone and I brought her
back but did I really bring her back you
know eats me up because I brought her
back but did I [__] up along the way did
I do something wrong that's what's
bugging me because I she's not the same
person that I knew she's somebody
different and I got to get used to it
but at the same time where is that
person you know I mean I'm trying to
find that person and that person's not
in there I mean and he's like if you
know somebody for 20 years and something
happens when they come back
from from a near-death experience or
death experience they come back and they
come back a different person you know
I know I feel it every day I see it you
know I mean she used to talk loud and
grow fast
now she don't even talk unless you talk
to her and she talks real low
so it bugs me every day you know as soon
as people out there think oh yeah come
this kid roll and kick it skidwell will
[__] you around so [__] bad Skittle
has me real tight in the knot right now
because I'm not just me now now I gotta
worry about her because of the fact I
brought her back and I'm taking sure I
let her go
no it's the wrong thing how nice and you
would think that way but when I look at
it and I talk to her on my book where
did I [__] up at I tried to do
everything the way they tell you to do
it you know I mean with nor can you hit
somebody they wake up right away it took
her two days to come back
so you know I'm just here to let you
guys know and update that I'm cool I'm
doing all right oh I got my own room as
soon as they came and told me hey we'll
put you in a room right now let's go I
wasn't gonna wait any longer I thought
about it first now but then I'm in a
room where yeah you might have you don't
have no curfew you might have to check
in and out when you go to your room you
know get your key give your key but you
got no curfew other than that and the
thing about it is they help you here to
get off the streets so there's no excuse
for anybody being in a tent now before
there was or they don't want a house
because it took me seven years to get a
room but now I gotta now I'm just
waiting like next month or something
they're supposed to give me a one
bedroom over here like in third in Union
or something but these new buildings
they're putting up and then they just
give you a one bedroom and you wait for
your section A but you got your housing
and all that [__] so I'm doing all that
you know I'm doing all that and I'm
getting it through
HUD you know I mean the people that come
and schedule and help you out so I'm at
that point right now I'm cool a lot of
people you know a lot of rumors go wrong
out there that I was dead I've heard it
like five times already oh God damn oh
he got shot in the handle they ran them
over I've heard all these stories but I
just wanted to give an update you know
that I'm still out here I'm still doing
my thing I will be back and give some
more stories but I just want to give you
something that I haven't gave you before
Kumar
Johnny you're the best thanks Mark